bonjour roula talent jeu merci de
répondre à nos questions on le rappelle
donc le liban qui est confiné à partir
d'aujourd'hui pour trois jours en raison
du week-end pascal comment est perçu ce
confinement express au pays du cèdre
lassitude ou bien comme je vous posais
la question on se dit que finalement
trois jours après les longues semaines
de mise sous cloche
dernièrement c'était finalement pas la
mer à boire évidemment que c'est la mer
à boire
v que la situation est tellement
catastrophique sans confinement
mais quand même durant les fêtes de
toutes les façons les trois jours à
venir c'est pas c'est pas si important
le confinement serait dramatique cas si
après ces trois jours il l'a décideront
de nous garder confiné c'est ce que les
gens ont besoin de sortir surtout ceux
qui travaillent au jour le jour quoi ils
pourraient pas avoir le plaisir de
rester à la maison alors il devrait être
essayer de ramener du pain on sait qu'il
est donc la crise sanitaire a évidemment
au liban comme partout dans le monde
mais au liban plus qu'ailleurs il ya la
crise économique et à la crise politique
qui perdure depuis plusieurs mois
plusieurs années après les un mois après
les menaces du premier ministre par
intérim à ces diables de ses fonctions
samedi diable lui-même démissionnaire a
qui gère d'ailleurs les affaires
courantes du pays
il avait menacé de partir si un
gouvernement n'est pas formé rapidement
un mois après cette annonce ou est-ce
qu'on en est c'est toujours le statu quo
c'est toujours le statu quo et c'est
surtout que avec ou sans gouvernement
nous ne pensons pas qu'il aura un
changement c'est une c'est une question
de changement de politique de politique
vis-à-vis des dpi qui nous viennent en
aide d'habitude avec gouvernement ou pas
je ne vois pas je ne vois pas l'horizon
va pas comment ça va changer
c'est un pays qui a été volé jusqu'au
dernier sou il nous reste 12 milliards
de dollars
des de l'argent des gens pas dans les
banques qui sont en train d'être d'être
volé en ce moment dans un an à la fin de
mai même les civils et l'argent du
peuple libanais dans les banques ne sera
plus alors je ne vois pas comment un
gouvernement va pouvoir faire face à la
catastrophe économique et finance et
monétaire à laquelle on fait face mais
alors ça il peut faire unige et les
choses dernièrement sur notre antenne
c'est d'ailleurs moi qui vous
interviewez vous en atelier à emmanuel
macron pour qu'une enquête
internationale soit ouverte en en suisse
notamment tout à fait tout à fait le
seul moyen
le seul moyen c'est un de nous
débarrasser de cette classe mafieuses
qui nous gouvernent depuis 30 ans qui a
qu'à voler le pays et le peuple libanais
de nous aider à mettre la main sur leur
sur leurs fonds qui sont entre londres
et la suisse et ailleurs et leurs biens
leurs biens en france
un peu partout dans le monde et surtout
en europe mettre la main sur cet argent
le rapatrier à un moment donné après la
formation d'un gouvernement
apolitique un gouvernement qui fait
qu'ils soient formés de gens capables de
gérer une société
voilà le liban a besoin d'une chine de
mesures extraordinaires pour pour le
sortir du gouffre où il est
les la politique la politique d'aidé des
classes de la classe a poli de la classe
mafieuses qui nous gouvernent ne peut
plus ne peut plus remédier à la
catastrophe dans laquelle nous sommes il
faut vraiment qu'on se débarrasse de ces
gens là et que peut faire la communauté
internationale mettre la pression
mettre la pression très fort parce que
même raymond vraiment la plus tard dont
elle le fait vraiment mettre la pression
la communauté internationale
discours notamment depuis l'explosion du
port de beyrouth en août dernier on sait
que paris a appelé à former rapidement
un nouveau gouvernement sinon il y avoir
des sanctions est ce que c'est ce que la
communauté internationale agisse
vraiment vous appelez à mai à ce qu'elle
fasse pression non pas tellement parce
que ils demandent à la même à la mène au
même club mafieux de former un
gouvernement et je ne vois pas comment
les mêmes gens qui ont détruit qui en
volley vont pouvoir médias la vraie
pression en retrait de 2 de leur faire
une pression telle que ils doivent
lâcher le morceau
ils doivent partir et le seul moyen est
donc c'est au peuple libanais de
continuer ce qu'il ira jusqu'au bout
bien la lassitude la résignation
commence à gagner les esprits du côté du
liban est tout à fait les gens sont là y
en eut stampa tous très fatigués c'est
en dehors du coville imaginez un pays
qui a le fait face à une crise sanitaire
énorme mais même les vaccins sont ils
les ont volés
on a eu droit à 120 millions de dollars
de prêts de la banque mondiale pour
vacciner la population libanaise
je pense 10% du peuple libanais a été
vaccinée même pas et s'est laissé les
suivants des partis politiques et les
autres maintenant on doit payer de notre
propre poche en encore jules va pour se
faire vacciner même ça ils n'ont pas su
gérer
alors vous imaginez un peu la l'état
catastrophique du libanais mais ça c'est
quand même bon parce que quand on n'a
plus le choix que d'être fort on l'est
évidemment
merci roue la tâche pour ces mots forts
ce matin sur sur l' art